Hey, this is Presh Talwalkar and you're watching Mind Your Decisions
A, B, and C have a party
Person A brings five cakes
Person B brings three cakes
Person C brings eight dollars
A, B, and C believe in sharing. They divide the cakes so everyone eats the same amount
Person C then splits the eight dollars to A and B fairly
How much should C pay to A and to B?
Now before I go on I want to mention a very popular educational video on YouTube begins by asking
Who doesn't like birthday cake?
I get that many people like cake and I use cake in my math problems, too
But as someone who does not eat birthday cake and does not regularly eat cake
I want to suggest maybe we can encourage eating healthier foods in our math problems?
So I originally heard this story told which chapatis a whole wheat unleavened flatbread
And I personally enjoy eating tortillas
In particular white corn tortillas are inexpensive and easily available to me
So let's encourage these healthier foods in our math problems
Furthermore my videos will make you so smart that even difficult problems will become easy to you.
In videos like this you'll see people requesting harder problems
And that's the best proof that these videos are teaching math to people around the world
Can you figure it out?
Give this problem a try and when you're ready keep watching the video for a solution
So person A brings five tortillas person B brings three tortillas and person C brings $8
Since there are eight tortillas and C has eight dollars
It seems like C should give one dollar per tortilla meaning five dollars to A and three dollars to B
But in fact the fair split is seven dollars to A and one dollar to B
Why is that?
Well to divide into three people. Let's cut each tortilla into three parts
Now we can count the number of parts and we'll see there are eight times three which equals twenty-four pieces in total
so each person should get
24 over 3 which equals 8 of these pieces
In order for the split to happen A needs to give seven pieces to C and
B needs to give one piece to C
So now you can see that every single person has the exact same amount of food
C is giving eight dollars for a total of eight pieces, which means each piece is worth one dollar
Consequently C should pay seven dollars to A
for those seven pieces and one dollar to B for that one piece
Did you figure it out?
Thanks for watching this video
These math videos inspire and build confidence for people around the world and they already have over a hundred million views
But the math meanies never praise them and spread negativity
Let's be extra positive to cancel them out
Please help by subscribing for free to get the newest videos and by watching and sharing all of the videos on mind your decisions
you can also email me a puzzle or math topic at presh [at] mindyourdecisions [dot] com
If you so choose you can also check out my books which are linked in the video description and you can support me on
Patreon to earn exclusive rewards
Thanks for watching and thanks for your support